today I will show you how to use the
skills overview report in the teacher
dashboard on Khan Academy
once you have logged into Khan Academy
go to your teacher dashboard
once you are in your teacher dashboard
on the left-hand panel under Tools click
activity overview
this will be the screen that will load
at the top there are two tabs activity
and skills today we are going to use the
skills tab once the skills tab loads you
will have several options on the top of
the screen you can choose the grade that
you want to look at
the units that you want to look at the
Mastery levels and there's an additional
box that you can check if you just want
to see assigned skills
so as I scroll down I see that there are
11 units and 148 skills I'm just going
to look at the ratios unit so if I click
ratios
this will expand the screen and I will
be able to see more information
so this is basic ratios one of the
skills
here's the common core standard and here
is actually the exercise I can look at
the actual exercise that the students
have completed under that you will see
the Mastery levels if I hover over the
Mastery levels it would explain to me
exactly what the student had to complete
in order to earn this Mastery level
I can also assign this assignment back
to the students right from this screen
so if I click this blue assign this
skill button a pop-up screen will appear
and it will allow me to pick my question
set whether I want to have a different
question set or the same question set it
would allow me to select or deselect
students that I want to have this
assignment
I can choose the start date the start
time the due date and the due time and
then I just click the assign button
it will bring me back to this screen
this is a great snapshot for you to be
able to see what level students are at
for different skill levels and to make
small groups and differentiate within
your classroom you can also take this
data back to plcs and revise your
teaching instruction in order to suit
the needs of the different students in
the different skill sets
another thing you can do with this
report is click on the individual
student
if I click on Victoria I will see just
her information at the top make sure
everything that you want to see is
clicked
so I'm gonna look at just the ratio so
I'm going to unselect everything and
just select ratios
and here I can see that she at the 148
skills she's practiced 13. here is the
Mastery levels that she's earned
and if I dig a little bit deeper I can
see that these are the things that were
assigned to Victoria here her current
Mastery levels and I can actually look
at the different assignments that were
assigned to her
this is a great tool for parent-teacher
conferences or IEP meetings or for
individual student conferences now I'll
go back to the main class page where I
see all my students
and I can go down to the next skill
level and I can see the same exact
information what students are performing
where and I can also assign the skill
see the Common Core Strand and also look
at the assignment
if you have any more questions about how
to use this report please for look for a
link in the description of this video in
order to gain access to more support
from Khan Academy about how to use this
report in your classroom